[Music]
Oh George
[Applause]
I'm steamed up to center screen
Westbrook got by split the defense and
elevates making man he's gonna give her
that pop on page and what better way to
express yourself you think what he just
did
Westbrook double-team they give it up to
Adams right back to Westbrook Corner
three George
[Music]
okay soon
[Applause]
it was all Paul George being Paul George
as we've seen it so much this season
folks the Thunder inching closer at the
head Josh this under team is coming
alive here at midway through the second
quarter makes the Paul George
push the turn around
[Applause]
to the back
as you can tell that's all of the
emotion that he plays with on that plate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there is dog off the feed from Westbrook
many had to go get that Missy you got
that ball hung up there forever it he
timed it perfectly
they can get the time Westbrook on the
drive
[Applause]
it grabs the loose ball goes
coast-to-coast knifes his way through
the rafters defense and fight the ball
him
[Music]
they clear the line
[Applause]
that's nasty gross especially their
golden time an emphatic dunk for the
seven-time all-star you got to think
Paul George has to get a touch at some
point and he does the three ball quickly
George all on the job incredible that
was an incredible great shot lunch
Paul George now with 30 points see what
George does tribes off
you know what we call that individual
supremacy on full display and George
the logic is shot the night what up and
your boy out of love codes you like that
content I know you like that content hit
subscribe for more of it from Bleacher
Report